of course we're beginning to wrap things
up here uh at tbs that means we have two
weeks to go
ending on thursday june 24th that's
right after uh it's hard to believe
after 28 years i'll be leaving the
nightly
format we have so many exciting guests
coming
up in the next two weeks including jack
black
bill hader martin short mila kunis
a couple of great surprise drop ins we
have still
not announced our guest for next tuesday
but trust me it's going to be somebody
huge
like meryl streep or george clooney
or jack mcbreyer it could be
so it could be anybody yeah yeah anybody
yeah anybody huge like oprah
or leonardo dicaprio or jack mcprayer
so it could be why do you keep saying
jack mcgregor
it's an example andy okay okay it's like
it could be beyonce it really could
it could be president barack obama it
could be
jack mcbrear yeah see i have a hunch
that it's going to be jack mcbride
maybe maybe not you just don't know
do you really think it could be
wow well
jack i got to say thank you so much uh
for being here you know you have been
a great friend of the show over the
years you're such a talented guy
this guy did sketches for us uh when he
was not
famous yet when we did the late night
show
you did you before you were you were a
complete unknown you did sketches for us
and i kept putting you on and putting
you on and probably
launched your career and
the point is uh you've been great to us
you've been an integral part of
everything we've done really since the
beginning so
sure you can be the guest next tuesday
yeah
that means so much to me i'm gonna go
call my parents and tell them right now
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all right okay thank you
okay well that was jack mcbrayer
everybody
[Applause]
he's 48
well he was four right right
yeah past tense yeah well i guess it
won't be jack mcgregor yeah
i'm not dead everyone
jack are you okay i'm fine but i did
cause a terrible accident
the police are looking for me but you
can still be here
next tuesday right oh no sir i am guilty
of vehicular
homicide i'll be on the lamb
goodbye jack mcprayer everybody
i've never heard anyone say vehicular
homicide in such a happy way